und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend heute hat der deutsche bundestag
beraten und entschieden dass deutsche
truppen fürs erste weiter machen mit
ihrem beschränkten einsatz im norden des
irak
da war die verteidigungsministerin schon
in brüssel in einem kreis in dem sich
niemand mehr dafür interessiert wie
stilvoll oder nicht sie ihren
außenminister kollegen maß zu
informieren pflegt im nato ministerrat
ging es um das große bild das allerdings
mittlerweile ganz andere beherrschen die
neuen herren sitzen in moskau russlands
verteidigungsminister telefoniert mit
dem chef der chaotischen milizen in
syrien und blicke auf ihn wie auf einen
befehlsempfänger das ist die realität
mit der die verteidigungsminister der
nato politik machen müssen es geht um
die nachkriegsordnung für syrien oder
besser um die rolle die der westen darin
spielen soll
die antwort am ende des tages wir haben
verschiedene ansichten und die
bündnispartner haben das auch offen
gesagt es gibt eine starke unterstützung
für eine politische lösung und für ein
stärkeres nationales engagement
woran genau sie dabei denkt hätten viele
teilnehmer heute gern genauer erfahren
doch annegret kramp-karrenbauer deshalb
verraten hatte keine details im gepäck
am morgen im glanz seines brüssler
ballsaals sei es für einen moment so aus
als habe der vorschlag aus berlin
selbst beim us verteidigungsminister
eine chance
er habe ich nicht gelesen aber ich denke
das ist gut denn wir bitten unsere
europäischen partner seit einer ganzen
weile darum also unterstütze ich das
doch dann schien ich unterstütze das
politisch wir wollen keine bodentruppen
stehen bleiben die europäischen partner
doch auch die haben vor dem treffen
fragen zu details und zum teil
wir sind nicht grundsätzlich gegen eine
internationale sicherheitszone aber die
lage vor ort hat sich weiterentwickelt
jetzt da sich die türkei und russland
geeinigt haben schöne idee aber ohne uns
das war oft die position deutscher
verteidigungsminister die neue probt den
rollentausch zuerst trifft sie den
türkischen kollegen und kann berichten
dass es sich sehr offen gezeigt hat im
bilateralen gespräch dass dies auch
unter einbeziehung der internationalen
gemeinschaft erfolgen könnte dass die
türkei dazu zu gesprächen auch bereit
ist im kreise aller macht kramp
karrenbauer mit nur zwei sätzen werbung
für ihren vorschlag so berichten
teilnehmer aus ihrer sicht aber hat sie
damit schon ihr ziel erreicht insofern
ist der diskussionsprozess angestoßen
das wird noch ein langer prozess ein
schwieriger weg aber die ersten schritte
die ersten gespräche heute waren sehr
ermutigend
die deutsche ministerin steht in brüssel
heute noch allein
aber nach diesem tag will keiner
ausschließen dass das so bleiben muss
stefan leifert ist unser nato
korrespondent in brüssel
stefan ist im kollegenkreis von annegret
kramp karrenbauer gar nicht klarer
geworden welchen plan sie hat nein nicht
so richtig und das scheint wohl die eine
große strategische schwäche dieses
vorstoßes aus berlin zu sein
keiner hat sich hier heute demonstrativ
vor die kameras gestellt und die
rückendeckung gegeben
im grundsatz finden die idee den
syrien-konflikt oder die syrien lösung
zu internationalisieren und den
europäern auch hier in eine rolle zu
geben gut aber dennoch flog die idee aus
berlin heute nicht so richtig und dafür
gibt es vor allem zwei gründe der eine
ist dass sich viele nicht so richtig und
viel zu spät informiert fühlen es gibt
nach wie vor nichts schriftliches auch
heute muss wohl vieles im vagen und
nebulösen geblieben seien und auch die
deutsche rolle der deutsche beitrag ist
nicht so richtig klar herausgearbeitet
worden eine zweite schwäche ist die dass
viele in der nato auch gar nicht die
richtige plattform sehenden
kramp-karrenbauer will ja auch die
russen mit einbinden und dann sagen
viele sind die vereinten nationen
eigentlich die bessere plattform dafür
also hier scheint es heute eine gute
eine gute idee gegangen zu sein die aber
schlecht angepackt wurde nun verhalten
sich ja putin und erdogan erkennbar so
als hätten sie die lösung untereinander
ausgemacht und sind dabei sie umzusetzen
ist da überhaupt noch irgendwo platz für
einen deutschen europäischen oder
sonstwie westlichen beitrag ja das
scheint die andere und viel
grundsätzlichere schwäche dieses
vorstoßes zu sein die letzten tage haben
ja noch mal eindrucksvoll vor augen
geführt wie sehr hier andere mächte als
die europäer oder der westen in der
syrische nachkriegsordnung schon fakten
geschaffen haben das vakuum was die
amerikaner durch ihren abzug aus
nordthüringen jetzt hinterlassen das
könnte so eine letzte chance für die
europäer oder für die nato oder für die
vereinten nationen seien in dieser
syrischen nachkriegsordnung noch
irgendwie einen fuß in die tür zu
kriegen aber es gibt auch hier bei der
nato manche die glauben dafür ist es
längst zu spät
danke für die einschätzung nach brüssel
und damit zur deutschen innenpolitik zur
letzten landtagswahl dieses jahres in
thüringen dem einzigen bundesland in dem
die linkspartei den regierungschef
stellt bodo ramelow am anderen ende des
politischen spektrums dort einer
fd die von ihrem rechtsnationalen flügel
beherrscht wird unter seinem anführer
blöcke die umfragen und da haben wir
gleich die neueste und letzte vor der
wahl die umfragen zeigen dass die
regierungsbildung schwierig werden
könnte aber erstmal eindrücke von der
stimmung im land drei tage vor der wahl
noch schnell eine tasse kaffee 10 v6 in
creuzburg im wartburgkreis der gelernte
karosseriebauer jürgen blätter auf fährt
zur schicht zum opel werk nach eisenach
auf seinen diesel ist der 57-jährige
angewiesen auch weil der bus nicht
passend fährt der ländliche raum droht
weiter abgehängt zu werden so seine
sorge kaufläden verschwinden becker
verschwinden wenn die infrastruktur
nicht mehr stimmt dann waren warum die
leute ab das hatten wir schon mal ein
bonbon bohrungen nach der wende jugend
wetterau will das nicht noch einmal
erleben was er nach dem zusammenbruch
der ddr mitgemacht hat der betriebsrat
befürchtet dass mit dem umstieg vom
diesel auf elektro in der hier so
wichtigen automobilbranche viele jobs
verloren gehen
die wartburgregion rund um eisenach hat
von der deutschen einheit stark
profitiert nach umbruch und
massenarbeitslosigkeit sind rund um opel
und bosch und bmw tausende jobs
entstanden alles gut wäre da nicht die
sorge vor dem was kommt war der jetzt
werden viele sachen zugemacht viele
zulieferer für die industrie und das
wort hohen problem langfristig jetzt
werden von der angst profitiert auch die
afd wahlkampf mit einfachen antworten
auf komplexe fragen
alles hängt mit allem zusammen der
klimawandel die jobs die zuwanderung die
zukunft die ängste der bevölkerung
werden geschürt eben gerade von der afg
haben jetzt zwar nicht wirklich wege
diese aufweisen weil wir besser machen
könnten aber die angst darf man da
landrat reinhard krebs führt den
wartburgkreis flächenmäßig der größte
kreis ganz thüringens der cdu mann ist
ein pragmatiker sucht kleine lösungen in
einer komplexen feld aber so wie die
busse kommen auch die politischen
botschaften nicht immer an die
kommunikation ist gestört wir haben ein
sehr komplexes leben mittlerweile und
wenn dann jemand kommt und
einfache antworten auf komplexe fragen
hat dann könnte es natürlich sein dass
ein bürger sagten ja das verstehe ich
zumindest aber man muss bei allen
problemen tiefe schauen
der schwarze landrat und katja wolf die
rote bürgermeisterin von eisenach sind
nachbarn mit gemeinsamen interessen hier
geht etwas was auf landesebene bislang
ausgeschlossen ist pragmatismus statt
ideologie die probleme fordern eine
zusammenarbeit in eisenach steht die
aufgabe dass wir nicht nur die
verlängerte werkbank sind das sondern
das viel viel stärker auch der bereich
forschung und entwicklung sich hier
entwickeln kann
das forschungseinrichtungen eisenach
angesiedelt werden dass man genau diesen
bereich der moment noch viel zu schwach
ist in der zukunft auch mit voranbringt
davon würde die ganze region profitieren
und so hofft auch jürgen wetter und das
nach der wahl einer regierungen
thüringen zustande kommt die seinen
landkreis im blick behält
und auch vor der thüringen wahl macht
das zdf was es immer macht vor
landtagswahl nämlich ganz knapp davor
die forschungsgruppe wahlen mit einer
letzten befragung beauftragen
matthias sie machen das was sind die
ergebnisse ist ja guten abend so ist es
also das ist die letzte umfrage vor dem
aktuellen wahlsonntag das ist eine
stimmungsaufhellung sorgen nicht so wird
es ausgehen also keine prognose hier
sind die zahlen
die cdu käme auf 26 prozent die linke
auf 28 prozent plus 1 im vergleich zur
vorwoche könnte damit erstmals stärkste
parteien ein bundesland werden spd 9%
afd 21 prozent verdoppelt ihr ergebnis
gegenüber der letzten landtagswahl grüne
7 prozent 5 prozent ungefähr für die fdp
vier prozent die anderen parteien
zusammen nun sieht man das nicht auf den
ersten blick aber sie haben ja schon
gesagt das wird eine schwierige
regierungsbildung bis etwa so ausgeht
absoluten das liegt natürlich auch daran
dass die afg über 20 prozent das heißt
jeder fünfte abgeordnete im parlament
fällt eigentlich aus für eine
mehrheitsbildung weil niemand sonst mit
der afg regieren will
die cdu hat ausgeschlossen mit der
linkspartei zu regieren und dann wirds
halt richtig knapp rot-rot-grün regiert
im moment linkspartei geführt mit bodo
ramelow und dieses bündnis hätte nach
unseren zahlen keine mehrheit im moment
das kann sich schon noch bewegen aber im
moment sieht so aus und deshalb ist viel
die rede von einer minderheitsregierung
das kann so kommen muss aber nicht also
auf jeden fall ein spannender
wahlsonntag vorbei die thüringer schon
eine klare präferenz haben was den
ministerpräsidenten angeht absolut das
ist bodo ramelow der amtierende
ministerpräsident der hat einen klaren
amtsbonus ist beliebt im lande
wir erinnern uns vor fünf jahren da gab
es noch ein aufschrei wie kann ein
linker ministerpräsident werden das hat
sich sehr gelegt und ramelow ist eine
art zug fährt auch für die linke was
dazu führt dass sie so stark dasteht
anders als in brandten brandenburg und
sachsen anfang september
wir sehen hier in thüringen im grunde
genommen keine wechselstimmung wen
wollen sie lieber als
ministerpräsidenten haben lieber bodo
ramelow sagen 54 prozent der thüringer
und nur 29 prozent mike mohring von der
cdu keine wechselstimmung also in den
zahlen erkennbar es könnte und müsste
eng und spannend werden dann müssen wir
abwarten bis zum ja danke schön
es gibt natürlich wie immer mehr
hintergründe und informationen zur wahl
in thüringen auf heute.de und nun die
nachrichten von gundula gause und da
schleicht sich der praxis wieder ins
programm
der britische premierminister boris
johnson hat sich für neuwahlen am 12
dezember ausgesprochen
einen entsprechenden antrag werde er im
parlament stellen erklärte er in der bbc
wenn das parlament tatsächlich mehr zeit
haben wolle um die praxis gesetze zu
studieren könne es das haben der eu
austritt würde sich damit noch länger
hinziehen
für neuwahlen braucht johnson die
zustimmung von zwei dritteln der
abgeordneten also auch von labour
vertretern deren chef corbijn machte am
abend klar dass er neuwahlen
unterstützen würde wenn ein no deal
drexhage vom tisch sei eine aktuelle
studie zu vermehrtem antisemitismus in
deutschland lässt politiker dringend ein
stärkeres vorgehen gegen
judenfeindlichkeit fordern laut der
studie des jüdischen weltkongresses hegt
mehr als jeder vierte deutsche
antisemitische ansichten 41 äußern
demnach die meinung juden redeten zu
viel über den holocaust
die studie zeigt zudem dass sich
antisemitismus auch unter
hochschulabsolventen verbreitet 28
prozent von ihnen gaben an juden hätten
zu viel macht in der wirtschaft der afg
droht eine weitere strafzahlung in höhe
von 396 1000 euro das ist das dreifache
einer spende aus der schweiz die die
bundestagsverwaltung nachprüfung für
illegal hält die afg soll sich nun zu
der schweiz spende äußern
in der spendenaffäre wurden bereits hohe
strafzahlungen verhängt die afg klagt
gegen die bescheide der bundestag hat
eine reihe von gesetzen verabschiedet
darunter einen mindestlohn von 515 euro
monatlich für azubis im ersten lehrjahr
damit sollen die berufsausbildung
attraktiver gemacht und abbrecherzahlen
verringert werden außerdem verbessert
das parlament die absicherung von
paketboten wenn ein sub unternehmer für
sie keine sozialbeiträge ab führt wird
per gesetz der hauptunternehmer
verpflichtet brandenburg soll künftig
von einer rot schwarz grünen koalition
regiert werden
knapp acht wochen nach der landtagswahl
haben sich spd cdu und grüne auf einen
koalitionsvertrag verständigt die
mitglieder der parteien müssen noch
zustimmen
ministerpräsident soll dietmar woidke
von der spd bleiben dessen bisheriges
bündnis mit der linken die mehrheit
verloren hatte die 39 toten die gestern
in einem lkw anhänger in england
entdeckt wurden stammen aus china
die britische polizei erklärte zugleich
die todesursache sei weiter unklar
womöglich sind die 31 männer und acht
frauen im inneren des kühl anhängers
erfroren
laut ermittlern kam er über seebrücke in
belgien nach england der 25 jährige
fahrer des lkw wurde unter mordverdacht
festgenommen
nicht bekannt ist weiterhin ob er
überhaupt wusste dass die menschen in
den anhänger waren es gibt in der
spanischen sprache kein wort für
vergangenheitsbewältigung den zentralen
begriff für deutschlands
auseinandersetzung mit sich selbst nach
holocaust und weltkrieg die spanier
hatten keinen bedarf an so einem wort da
wurde nichts bewältigt die vergangenheit
war nicht mal vergangen der faschist
francisco franco hatte 1939 die
demokratie in einem blutigen bürgerkrieg
geschlagen und herrschte ununterbrochen
und unbewältigte bis 1975 gnadenlos
autoritär ein übermächtiger führer der
sich von zwangsarbeitern ein monument
von grab errichten ließ dass alle zeiten
überdauern sollte 40 jahre demokratie
hat das faschismus denkmal überdauert
linke und rechte regierungen bis jetzt
die linke regierung sanchez den
politischen kraftakt wagte umbettung des
caudillo thomas walde bericht faust und
canales war zwei jahre alt als sein
vater erschossen wurde weil er in einer
gewerkschaft war er wurde opfer francos
wo der ehemalige diktator spaniens
begraben liegt ist für fausto bedeutsam
überreste des diktators sind so einen
privilegierten platz geehrt in einem
mausoleum dass er zu seinem glanz und
seiner größe errichten ließ wir finden
es gut dass sie ihn da rausholen in eg
das massige monument das franco für sich
selbst von zwangsarbeitern in den
bergbauern dies wurde zu einer
pilgerstätte für ewiggestrige
die regierung wollte nicht mehr dass der
faschistische diktator hier seine ruhe
findet heute schließt spanien mit einem
dunklen kapitel ab mit dieser
entscheidung wird eine moralische na
frau ein ende gesetzt
die öffentliche verherrlichung des
diktators war mehr als ein anachronismus
oder eine anomalie sie war ein
schwerwiegender marke für die spanische
demokratie francisco franco hatte 1936
gegen die regierung geputscht
es folgte ein fast dreijähriger
bürgerkrieg den die franken gewannen
hunderttausende gegner wurden ermordet
franco regierte spanien bis an sein
lebensende 1975
heute morgen liest die regierung den
zugang zu seinem mausoleum sperren
sie wollte kein öffentliches spektakel
einzelne anhänger francos äußerten sich
gleichwohl entführt wen stört es denn
dass er hier ist doch nur die roten uns
nicht welche notwendigkeit gibt es denn
wirklich jemanden nach 40 jahren aus dem
grab zu holen
20 mitglieder der familie francos waren
heute mittag anwesend militärische ehren
gab es nicht auch wurde der sarg nach
dem willen der regierung nicht mit einer
spanischen flagge therapiert für
angehörige der opfer wie fausto canalis
ist das ein wichtiger aber auch nur ein
zwischenschritt sein vater liegt noch
nahe francos mausoleum fausto fordert
ein eigenes mahnmal für opfer wie seinen
vater
es gab immer schwierigkeiten unter
anderem weil franco dort lag es kann
jetzt also sein dass es leichter wird
dass sie wieder bekommen der überreste
unserer angehörigen abtransport eines
ehemaligen diktators es war ein tag an
dem in spanien die erinnerung an die
toten auf lebte und bei den angehörigen
der opfer die hoffnung dass sie den
frank ismus nunmehr hinter sich lassen
können zur deutschen wirtschaft und
ihrer wichtigsten sparte automobile eine
premiere heute
vw stellte die neue generation des golf
vor unentbehrlich aber routine nichts
für industrie geschichtsbücher es ist
schon die achte generation und wird
weiter von verbrennungsmotoren
angetrieben
der bericht von michael beverunger aus
dem landesstudio sachsen geht auch um
volkswagen weist aber schon eher in die
zukunft kein anderer deutscher
autokonzern setzt so konsequent auf
elektromotoren bvb und da ist das neue
produkt aus zwickau der erste baustein
einer produktpalette von der volkswagen
schon bald millionen verkaufen will idee
3 oder id3 aber man kann das am besten
deutsche aussprechen
3 die dritte große massen idee nach
käfer und golf äußerlich bescheiden aber
entscheidend für
in zukunft das konzert das sein
elektromobil hoffnungsträger id3 ein
verkaufsschlager wird davon ist vw schon
jetzt überzeugt auch vom anblick her es
ist ein auto was aus meiner sicht
stimmig ist was aus den regen wird im
straßenbild und demzufolge auch eine
gewisse attraktivität mitbringt so ein
fahrzeug zu besitzen
entscheidend für den erfolg aber dürfte
etwas anderes werden nicht das was man
von draußen sehen kann sondern das was
drunter steckt der modulare electric
baukasten im vw jargon mbb sechs modelle
für drei konzernmarken bauen darauf auf
die batterie gibt es in varianten für
330 420 und 550 kilometer reichweite
elektroautos bieten jetzt alle
hersteller an der mwb ist das
alleinstellungsmerkmal von vw der i3 hat
einen riesen vorteil dass er auf einer
eigenständigen plattform basiert und auf
dieser plattform werden eine große
anzahl von fahrzeugen gebaut
dadurch können die kosten pro fahrzeug
was die entwicklungen auch was die
produktion an betrifft sehr niedrig sein
und noch etwas fällt auch bei der
produktion des id 3 der mensch wird
entbehrlicher maschinen vermessen die
spaltmaße wo früher zwei arbeiter per
hand und mit spalt lehre zugange waren
die zahl der roboter hat sich beim e
mobil schlicht verdoppelt der
automatisierungsgrad in der montage bei
vw steigt von 15 auf fast 30 prozent
noch wird der mensch aber gebraucht und
so viel verändert hat sich für den dann
doch nicht das auto braucht auch eine
kühlung genauso wie von obama hat den
also ist die klimaanlage rohbauten ist
auch gebühren notwendig das meiste
ändert sich beim antrieb der
elektromotor hat viel weniger bauteile
als ein verbrenner auch hier braucht es
zum bau weniger arbeite in zwickau
steigt die zahl der arbeitsplätze
trotzdem das liegt daran dass wir hier
die kapazität steigern
wir haben nur an sich in der alt
fertigung
in einer taktzeit von 120 sekunden
gearbeitet und wir haben jetzt in einer
taktzeit von nur 90 sekunden arbeiten
deutschlandweit aber streicht vw 7000
stellen die gesamte branche steht mit
der umstellung auf e mobilität vor einem
umbruch
ich glaube man darf der öffentlichkeit
nichts vormachen elektromobilität wird
netto arbeitsplätze kosten wir rechnen
damit dass in einer größenordnung bis
zum jahr 2030 15 bis 20 prozent der
arbeitsplätze wegfallen werden
der einstieg in die schöne neue e mobil
welt ist beim die drei übrigens co2
neutral
das garantiert vw für den gesamten
herstellungsprozess einstiegspreis mit
umweltbonus unter 26.000 euro die
finanzmärkte schauten heute auf die
letzte zinssitzung der europäischen
zentralbank unter der leitung von mario
draghi auch zum ende seiner achtjährigen
amtszeit blieb der rat bei seinem 0
zinskurs das hat bekanntlich einige
folgen frank bethmann
manch ein experte sagt ja ohne draghi
gäbe es den euro nicht mehr wie sehen
sie das
frage hat sich ja gerade zu beginn
seiner amtszeit viel richtig gemacht wir
erinnern uns an die große
griechenland-krise wie gegen den euro
und gegen einzelne euro länder
spekuliert wurde
regierungen waren nahezu unfähig zu
handeln da war es draghi der die ganze
macht seines mandates in die waagschale
warfen sinngemäß sagte die notenbank
werde alles unternehmen um den euro zu
bewahren alles easy be ready to do
whatever it takes einsatz für die
geschichtsbücher
wenn der euro weiterhin ein
erfolgsprojekt bleibt dann wird er als
derjenige eingehen der den euro
tatsächlich zusammengehalten hat in
schwierigen zeiten
aber er wird auch als jemand eingehen
der die geldpolitik sehr extrem benutzt
hat unter draghi sanken die leitzinsen
auf einen historischen tiefstand von 0,0
prozent unter draghi kaufte die ezb
insgesamt wertpapiere im wert von 2,6
billionen euro und damit nicht genug mit
seiner letzten amtshandlung verkündete
der italiener heute dass die ezb ab
november wieder neues
geld in die hand nimmt um weitere
papiere aufzukaufen
seine kritiker befürchten dass diese
extreme ausrichtung langfristig großen
schaden anrichten könnte für die sparer
für die altersvorsorge
aber auch für das finanzsystem insgesamt
fielen dank frank im vergangenen jahr
wurde fast 300.000 haushalten in
deutschland zeitweise der strom
abgestellt weil kunden ihre rechnungen
nicht pünktlich zahlten so die dem zdf
vorliegende antwort der bundesregierung
auf eine anfrage der grünen
betroffen sind vor allem bezieher von
grundsicherung die grünen kritisieren
knapp 300.000 stromsperren seien ein
armutszeugnis für ein reiches land wie
deutschland eine meldung vom
internationalen fußball in der
gruppenphase der europa league musste
der vfl wolfsburg beim belgischen
erstligisten kaa gent ran und trennte
sich 2 2 und ebenfalls auswärts und
unentschieden spielte
bundesliga-spitzenreiter borussia
mönchengladbach bei as rom 1 zu 1 der in
china inhaftierte uigurische
wirtschaftsprofessor ilham tohti erhält
den sacharow preis für menschenrechte
des europaparlaments seit jahrzehnten
setzte er sich unermüdlich für die
unterdrückte muslimische minderheit der
uiguren ein aber auch für den dialog mit
den han chinesen erklärte eben
parlamentspräsident soli und forderte
die sofortige freilassung tochter der
uigure war 2014 wegen des vorwurfs des
separatismus zu lebenslanger haft
verurteilt worden
2017 die tochter den weimarer
menschenrechtspreis wahrscheinlich haben
sie noch nie von dark tourism gehört
einem dunklen tourismus ein modetrend
für mit schönheit über fütterte menschen
die sich in herausgeputzten altstätten
und an smaragdgrünen buchten langweilen
sie werden dieses phänomen gleich
kennenlernen an einem ort der als symbol
der technologischen supermacht udssr
galt bis april 86 bis zum gau im
kernkraftwerk tschernobyl
die ukrainische regierung die für diese
besondere destination mittlerweile
verantwortlich ist will den tour
es muss auch dorthin fördern aparter
weise mit kunst christiansen hat das
erlebt dieses geräusch ist so was wie
der sound des kalten krieges in den 70er
und 80er jahren weltweit zu hören auf
radiofrequenzen das klopfende geräusche
städte amateurfunker und den rundfunk
niemand wusste woher es kam und was es
bedeutet durch die reaktorkatastrophe
von tschernobyl 1986 flog alles auf und
jahre später wurde bekannt es kam aus
dem wald in der nähe des reaktors von
dieser riesigen metall warnt sogar war
bis dahin eine streng geheime
radaranlage teil des sowjetischen
frühwarnsystems heute steht die radar
wand in der sperrzone von tschernobyl
und wird zum kunstobjekt 150 meter hoch
600 meter breit
laserstrahlen lichteffekte die künstler
wollen zeigen dass sich die ukraine von
der vergangenheit der sowjetunion gelöst
hat heute senden wir von hier ein
anderes signal an die welt dass wir
bereit sind die katastrophe unserer
vergangenheit besser zu verstehen und
dass wir ein neues land sind mit neuen
interessanten und kreativen leuten
unterwegs im sperrgebiet die ukraine
will dass sich das bild ändert dass ich
ins weltweite kollektive gedächtnis
eingebrannt hat künstler wurden
engagiert malerei am meiler valérie chor
schon aufs bild im stil von einer
besseren welt 18 x 85 meter groß direkt
am unglücksreaktor liegt die
strahlungsbelastung deutlich unter dem
von den behörden erlaubten grenzwert
wenn man mit einem für die ukraine so
tragischen und emotionalen thema
arbeitet muss man sehr sensibel sein
viele leute haben eine verbindung zu der
tragödie manche sagen es ist ein tolles
projekt andere finden dass man hier in
der sperrzone nichts machen sollte
rund 2500 menschen arbeiten heute noch
in dem atomkraftwerk
gerade ist schichtwechsel der künstler
hat sein werk ihnen gewidmet wir
produzieren zwar keinen strom mehr
aber es geht ja um die atomare
sicherheit denn hier gibt es noch immer
radioaktives material
das interesse an diesem ort ist groß wie
nie seitdem die düstere tv-serie
tschernobyl schonungslos die fehler und
lügen der sowjetregierung in szene
gesetzt hat kommen noch mehr touristen
hierher die eine oder andere schlechte
erinnerung mag durch die kunstaktion im
katastrophengebiet verblassen aber die
strahlende gefahr im sperrgebiet wird
bleiben im zdf geht es weiter mit
maybrit illner und dem thema syrien
unter anderem mit aussenminister maß und
mit so harten kenneth einer journalistin
die sich in dieser region auskennt und
auch im innenleben des bleiben sie bei
uns und wir sagen dass morgens
[Musik]
liebe zuschauer im norden wird windig
schultern ist ein regengebiet das liegt
direkt über der nordsee sie zu uns nach
deutschland rein aber der regen schwächt
sich weitgehend ab der wind nicht es
wird zum teil stürmische böen an der
nordsee geben in süddeutschland steigt
der luftdruck das sorgt immer noch für
ruhiges wetter heute nacht ab und zu mit
ein paar regenschauern noch an den alpen
und auch in der schwäbischen alb
ansonsten gibt es auch dann später
schauer hier an der nordsee
sonst wird es teilweise klar ein paar
nebelfelder bilden sich und morgen wird
es dann in norddeutschland recht
freundlich da wechseln sonne und wolken
allerdings und schleswig holstein und an
der nordsee sind die wolken dichter da
ziehen eben immer wieder kleinere
schauer durch bei diesem stürmischem
südwestwind in der mittleren süden ist
der wind schwächer
dafür ist der hochnebel noch ziemlich
dicht tagsüber nachmittags bekommt er
hier und da noch lücken und auch der
regen direkt an den alpen der lästern
nachmittags nach und am freundlichsten
wird auf der schwäbischen alb und im
schwarzwald da wechseln auch sonne und
wolken die temperaturen auch dort mit am
höchsten
bis zu 19 grad am oberrhein ansonsten 20
grad im osten sonst 14 bis 17 grad
und die aussichten es wird am samstag
stürmische norddeutschland sonntags
kommt ein regengebiet herein das bringt
kühlere luft und am montag haben wir nur
noch 8 bis 14 grad und jetzt schauen wir
uns mal den trend an
bis anfang november für hannover den
temperatur trend also anfang der woche
geht es runter mit der temperatur und
dann bleibt es eben bei temperaturen
höchsttemperaturen von fünf bis zehn
grad und in den mittelgebirgen könnte es
mitte nächster woche vielleicht auch
schon mal schneiden
ich wünsche noch einen schönen abend und
machen sie's gut